welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and i hope you're ready
for a heavy halloween as we have a ton
of new looks and plot details for
spider-man no way home yesterday the
internet was hit up with a lot of leaks
that even jay jonah jameson would have
been proud of and we have some first
looks at the green goblin costume
confirmation of what toby mcguire and
andrew garfield will be wearing some
plot leaks some plot leaks debunked and
a big spoiler look at mma we're gonna be
breaking it all down but obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you're
one of the three people that haven't had
the movie ruined by the internet then
you better get out of here at breakneck
speed like gwen stacy but also love a
like and subscribe to never miss a video
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into spider-man no
way home
okay so on friday there were several
leaks of the costumes we're about to
talk about floating around in dms i was
too busy chatting to hot babes online
all day to see them and that's what i'm
telling marvel if kevin feige comes a
knocking in addition to me definitely
not seeing them descriptions of the
suits were posted on subreddit marvel
studio spoilers the next day twitter
user ember on main said that they'd sent
in the images to the subreddit but as
they hadn't been given credit they
wanted to make him regret it so decided
to post them all over the internet it
youtube is a place where you can dmca
someone in a second and have their whole
channel removed if you want to without
even asking for rent so i'm not going to
be able to show all of the images in
this video but they are out there if you
want to look however what we do have is
someone who has knocked up concept of
what they look like and i think that
should be fine to go over as it's not
being created by sony now the first
thing i want to talk about is the three
spider-man suits we've known for a while
that andrew garfield and toby maguire
would be reprising their versions of
peter parker in the movie but we didn't
know whether this would be in brand new
costumes or not however we can confirm
that toby will be wearing his suit from
the raimi trilogy with garfield wearing
his one from the amazing spider-man 2.
honestly i think this is the best move
by the studio as to me these costumes
are absolutely perfect they're both
iconic to their versions as well and it
would be a real shame to not get these
in the mcu what sony and marvel would
run the risk of doing is putting them in
used suits that don't look as good and
it would also slightly detach the
characters from the versions that we
know and love ember also posted that
kirsten dunst will be in the film and
though it said that the villains will be
what if versions it is likely that the
two additional spider-men are gonna be
pulled across from their solo movies now
one costume that has changed up slightly
is the green goblin outfit as i said we
will be using fan mock-ups but they're
pretty much what was shown in the images
the costume is highly battle damaged and
it also comes with belts and pouches
that are full of the goblins tricks and
weapons first thing you're probably
gonna notice is that the green goblin
doesn't have a mask and instead he has
some goggles that look a lot like doctor
octopuses from spider-man 2. i have seen
a lot of people saying that they're
gonna add the mask but from what i've
heard this is how the goblin is gonna
look now why that is is because the
movie is basically gonna be pulling the
villains out of the multiverse the
second before they died as the goblin
wasn't masked and in a battle damaged
costume this is the version that's going
to be brought into the mcu you can even
see that the goblin costume looks very
similar to how it was when he got
stabbed in the dick and his guy's going
to be pulled across just after he got
stabbed in the deck yo now from what
i've heard when he comes into the mcu he
will take octopuses goggles and then
wear them a big criticism that people
had for the raimi costume was that you
basically paid for willem dafoe who has
a very iconic face and then covered it
up with a big green power rangers helmet
marvel is wanting to lean into defoe's
most notable features and this is why
this time around he won't be wearing the
mask now people have been going back and
forth on this overnight and for the last
couple of months over whether you should
wear masks and whether you shouldn't but
i did get told that he wouldn't have one
a while ago so it does kind of line up
with this concept art now i am actually
wondering whether they lean into some of
the original costume designs from 2002
as they would definitely work with
keeping his face on show but also having
him with a look that leans into the
comics if you think about how the
vulture looked in homecoming then this
does line up with that as being
something that has more of a real world
feel to it but let me know below what
you is think's to happen
now i think the costume looks absolutely
incredible and aaron s bailey did a
brilliant markup of the leaked scene
we'd heard about when goblin goes to the
villains that have been captured in
stranger sanctorum prison going beyond
that from what i've heard on the film
osborne will land in the mcu and he'll
be sort of torn between his two
personalities he will then wear a
blanket in order to make himself look
homeless and he'll go to aunt may's
feast operation and layla there after
peter captures the other villains and
locks them up he'll bump into him at
feast and this will be where he tries to
convince him to free them
we've already done a big plot leak video
on all the ins and outs that are missing
here so if you want to learn more then
that's going to be linked at the end now
goblin will sort of go back and forth
between wanting to free them and warning
them for his evil schemes but ultimately
the dark side will win and he'll become
the main villain now if you've been
watching our other plot leak videos then
you'll know we've talked about a big
death in the film i'm not going to drop
that here as i think it is quite a big
spoiler and i have to give another
spoiler warning which i really can't be
bothered with however apparently the
scene of the building on fire from the
trailer is this moment and after peter
attempts to stop goblin he goes to this
person's house and blows it up with them
inside it's pretty shocking and it
mirrors a big thing that also happened
in the raimi films making it like poetry
now earlier in the week it was debunked
that the rhino will be in the movie this
is something that we reported on for a
while and then i heard the opposite to
it and started putting my theories out
for who the final sinister six villain
would be but everyone called me a [ __ ]
because as we all knew it was definitely
rhino
i kind of feel like i should have just
went with my gut and said what i thought
instead of being like well all these
people must be the ones who are right
and i feel like i'm gonna have to make
another i was wrong video because
apparently he's not in the movie and
that being said all the latest reports
are saying that there are only five
villains in the film and this will be
goblin doc awk sandman electro and the
lizard the sinister five just sounds
very weird so if if there is a spot open
personally i'd love to see the scorpion
fill it i don't know whether he's in the
movie or not but there was a scorpion
robot included in the lego playsets and
if we look at the arc of the villain in
the mcu his return here makes a lot of
sense in the post-credits scene of
homecoming he was of course desperate to
find out spider-man's identity far from
home then revealed that and thus it just
makes sense to tie it all together and
have him be a villain in this one movie
climaxes normally pair people off with
their counterparts which is why in so
many final showdowns you get the male
main character fighting the male main
bad guy the female character fighting
the female one and so on and so forth i
think that tom needs an mcu villain to
fight off against and scorpion would
provide that otherwise he's just going
to be going head-to-head with people
from other universes i think they kind
of need to do scorpion as well as
otherwise it's been three movies now
where he hasn't sued up and it makes
that post-credits scene in homecoming
pretty pointless if we don't get a
payoff now the next trailer is something
that everyone on the internet is
desperate to see throughout the week we
got a lot of new clips that were labeled
as being leaks from the second trailer
but they've now been debunked as being
alternate takes that come from the first
one this included a scene in which peter
had just stopped a criminal and he then
had green paint thrown over his suit
shouts to cosmic wonder who earlier in
the week released this as a scoop and he
said that this is how peter actually
ends up getting his black costume the
scene actually starred tom holland's
brother as the bank robber and then
peter strung him up which is when he had
the paint thrown over him he can't wash
this out and he ends up turning the suit
inside out which is how he gets the
black one which is basically just the
red and black one reversed there was
also a mum which spider-man swung
through the city and he was grabbed by
dr strange's cloak with it sitting
around his shoulders like how it was and
what if this then pulled him back and
apparently leads into the moment from
the first look in which strange then
knocks peter out of his body so that he
can take the cube back there were also
some alternate takes of things like
strange chasing peter through new york
and a couple of additional shots of the
ladder being thrown against the wall
however we have to stress that this is
not the second trailer and it's just
alternate scenes from the first one that
ultimately didn't end up getting used as
for the trailer itself i don't think
it's gonna come until at least the
middle of november at the earliest we
now know from daniel rpk that mobius
will be dropping a brand new look on
tuesday so that pretty much rules the
next week out the week after it doesn't
have any big releases but the week after
that is ghostbusters afterlife to me
releasing it with that makes the most
sense as the film will be about a month
away and it also helps to promote one of
sony's films if they dropped it before
june or the eternals it would help to
push a warner brothers in marvel studios
movie whereas if it comes with
ghostbusters then it's a win-win for
sony now this is just me guessing but
looking at everything from a business
point of view i think that just makes
the most sense so in summary we don't
know when the trailer is the goblin suit
will be a battle damaged one from the
raimi verse toby and andrew will remain
in their most iconic suits kirsten dunst
will be in the film and the black suit
will be the red and black one reversed
overall i'm really hyped for the film
and i'm guessing that we still don't
have a poster yet because sony want to
reveal andrew and toby on it which is
why they've held off for so long as far
as official announcements go willem
dafoe hasn't been announced yet so i
think they're just keeping everything
under wraps and having andrew garfield
say all the time that he's not the
werewolf but you've been lying the whole
time i hate you you stop lying you
scumbag either way i'd love to hear i'm
sorry andrew either way i'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you drop them
below and let me know we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the zack snyder dc
trilogy on the 30th of november and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the news we picked the comments out
right now at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our full plot
league breakdown which will be linked on
screen right now we go over the ones we
kind of skim past in this video and also
just talk more about what we know in the
movie so definitely go and check that
out if you just love them spoilers if
not then thank you for sitting through
this video i've been poor let's see on
the next one you take care peace
[Music]
baby